[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
public sénat qu'est-ce qui n'a pas
fonctionné dans la gestion de l'épidémie
de coronavirus qu'est-ce qui peut être
doit être améliorée notamment au niveau
administratif c'est tout l'objet de la
commission denquête mise en place cet
été par le sénat aujourd'hui c'est
gérald darmanin actuel ministre de
l'intérieur qui est auditionné on
regarde l'audition on en reparle juste
après je le jure je jure si je vous cède
la parole pour une dizaine de minutes
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les desserts monsieur les
rapporteurs c'est évidemment respectueux
du du pouvoir parlementaire est
évidemment ray obéissant au pouvoir de
votre commission denquête que je garde
ministre on a eu la rigueur de porter le
masque en permanence y couvrir merci
merci du coup conscient de votre votre
pouvoir de l'audition que je me rends
bien évidemment à votre audition ce
ignore cependant que vous avez devant
vous un ministre de l'intérieur qui est
en fonction depuis le 6 juillet et qui
ne peut répondre que des actes qu'il a
acquis la komine même s'il peut être
éclairée du travail par ses passes et
direction et paris nord du ministère de
la gestion par le ministère de
l'intérieur et vous l'avez souligné vous
même monsieur le président de la
question de l'interministérialité la
crise que nous connaissons vous savez
mieux que personne et est à la fois
exceptionnel et est inédite par son
ampleur à la propagation du virus sur le
fait que la crise n'est épargné aucun
territoire qu'elle a évidemment une
durée exceptionnellement longue et
qu'elle s'agit d'une crise sanitaire
pour lequel nous avons beaucoup innové
au ministère de l'intérieur qui vous le
savez à la foi et à ministère de gestion
de crise notamment par l'intermédiaire
du corps préfectoral
parce qu'il a dû appliquer un certain
nombre de dispositions décidées par le
parlement
singulièrement lorsque les policiers les
gendarmes ont dû verbaliser aussi parce
que avec les agents de sociétés de la
sécurité civile par dont il a pu
intervenir notamment pour aider à la
propagation des bons soit au moment où
la propagation du virus était le plus le
plus évident quelques chiffres
témoignant de l'ampleur vous le savez
bien plus de 9 millions de cas dans le
monde et au plan national 400 4890 cas
confirmés et un nombre de décès au 14
septembre de 31000 45
c'est donc une crise globale que le
gouvernement a dû affronter et
singulièrement le ministère de
l'intérieur
à l'intérieur de ce gouvernement dans
les fonctions précédentes je n'ai pas eu
à gérer la crise autrement que
économiquement dans le soutien avec bleu
de la mer au dispositif de la vie
économique
mais il est évident que le ministère de
l'intérieur a travaillé sous l'autorité
du premier ministre au travail
interministériel que vous évoquez sans
doute et qui sera l'objet j'imagine de
vos questions après avoir été l'objet du
questionnaire je voudrais souligner que
depuis son émergence
la gestion de cette crise est vraiment
interministériel l'organisation du
ministère de l'intérieur a été
pleinement mobilisés sous ce titre là et
notamment le fait qu'il a été incarné
dès aujourd'hui au lendemain du
confinement par le centre
interministériel de crise de cic que les
français ont vu à la télévision et qui
vise à donner une réponse nationale
unifiée qui a coordonné l'ensemble
d'action des ministères qui
investissaient dans les autorités
locales compétentes au niveau national
le sujet de la gestion de crise du
corona virus qu'il s'agisse de la santé
des transports de l'économie de
l'agriculture de l'outre-mer évidemment
la sécurité ces ministères se sont
réunit quotidiennement à l'occasion de
réunions thématiques interministériel
notamment au début de la crise
parallèlement la cellule situation du
cic accueilli les officiers de liaison
des ministères permettant de préparer
les points de situation quotidien est
préparé et éclairer les décisions des
autorités politiques
l'objectif premier de cette gestion
interministérielle a été clair la
mobilisation totale de tous les services
de l'état au niveau central comme au
niveau déconcentré sans interruption
depuis janvier soit plus de neuf mois
d'action continue c'est une durée sans
équivalent dans l'histoire de gestion
crise du ministère de l'intérieur pour
autant je voudrais le souligner l'état
s'est montré résilient et a su répondre
je le crois aux défis qui se sont
nombreux et origines opposé à lui le cic
dans la création à la compacité est
capable de déconfinement en prolongement
des travaux menés par délégué
interministériel à stratégie de
confinement a permis de gérer la crise
dans sa durée et continuent à le faire
dans une difficulté sans doute un peu
plus plus grande dans la crise et et est
longue et parfois les éléments
d'information différent de semaine en
semaine
au sein de cette organisation
interministérielle évidemment le
ministre l'intérieur a eu un rôle pivot
dans la gestion de crise conformément à
la tradition qui veut que c'est bien le
ministère de l'intérieur qui gère et qui
coordonne les crises que nous avons pu
connaître
il est en effet responsable de
l'anticipation du suivi des crises il
est chargé de la conduite opérationnelle
des crises au territoire de la
république en application de l'article l
1142 2 du code de la défense
il doit également au titre de la
préparation la gestion de crise
s'assurer la transposition et de
l'application au niveau déconcentré
notamment par l'intermédiaire du corps
préfectoral
des plans gouvernementaux dans le cadre
de cette crise du ministère a mobilisé
trois niveaux d'abord au niveau central
il est par exemple organisé sur le
retour sera international des français
qui étaient à one au début de la crise
en lien avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères et de la santé
il a aussi armé à titre principal c'est
personnel la majorité des postes du cic
tout en veillant au maintien en
conditions opérationnelles de cet organe
au niveau opérationnel les forces de
l'ordre ont la charge contrôle du
respect des règles sanitaires et
notamment le port du masque avait plus
de 45000 verbalisation depuis mais ils
sont aussi en charge la sécurité de nos
concitoyens dans un contexte de grande
tension
les sapeurs pompiers par exemple à
travers l'activité des icd moyens
nationaux la direction générale la
sécurité civile ont été pleinement
mobilisés parmi les plus de 123 mille
interventions locaux vides les prises en
charge par les hélicoptères de la
sécurité civile qui ont été de 326 et
pour l'évacuation sanitaire de plus de
282 personnes sans oublier les actions
des associations agréées de sécurité
civile qui dépendent en lien avec le
ministère de l'intérieur
de la sécurité civile et au niveau
territorial bien sûr les préfets et les
sous-préfets on était évidemment au
rendez vous notamment en lien avec les
acteurs économiques mais aussi les
conseils départementaux et les maires la
gestion de cette crise a reposé et
repose encore sur le couple préfet maire
est maire constituent en effet depuis le
début vous le savez mieux personnes des
partenaires essentiels et
incontournables renforcée par le travail
qu'ont pu faire les présidents des
conseils départementaux et régionaux
enfin cette crise monsieur président
doit sans doute nous amener et c'est la
réflexion que j'ai souhaité engager
devant le corps préfectoral dès mon
arrivée au ministère de l'intérieur à
nous interroger sur les perspectives
d'évolution des gestions de crise dans
notre pays et même si le retour
d'expérience n'est pas encore tout à
fait totale puisque le ministre de
l'intérieur comme tout le gouvernement
est encore mobilisés pour la gestion de
la crise du coronavirus il faudra nous
interroger ensemble sur les leçons que
nous pouvons retenir de cette crise
inédite sans me livrer à cet exercice
aujourd'hui parce qu'il est bien trop
tôt pour le faire et je n'ai pas assez
de remonter je voudrais vous faire
partager quelques pistes de réflexion
d'abord la crise sanitaire liée aux
copies 19e en exergue la multiplication
des crises dans notre société les
ampleurs les caractère polymorphe mais
aussi les conséquences sur notre
organisation doit nous permettre de
réfléchir et d'anticiper les prochaines
crises qu'elles soient sanitaires ou
autre et il me semble que c'est bien
abou vaut que cela peut être le centre
de réflexion pour les pour les mois et
les années à venir
par ailleurs nous devons réfléchir aux
moyens de renforcer notre organisation
et de l'adapter aux formes de crise
globale et durable c'est un axe
stratégique majeure de la feuille de
route du ministère de l'intérieur que
j'ai le proposer au premier ministre
plusieurs pistes et je voudrais terminer
par ceux là peuvent être évoqués d'abord
la gestion territorialisée de la crise
seul modèle pertinent pour adapter la
réponse de l'état aux réalités du
terrain et singulièrement l'échelon
départemental
à cet égard les prérogatives du couple
préfet de département et élu local pour
être davantage de consolider et
notamment nous inspirant de ce qui s'est
passé en retour d'expérience de la crise
du coronavirus il s'agit également
d'affirmer le rôle central de la cellule
interministérielle qui est placé à
beauvau en renfort
son outil d'anticipation et de
planification et en intégrant davantage
des dimensions technologiques et en
confortant le ministère de l'intérieur
comme le ministère de la gestion de
crise enfin il s'agit de consolider
l'offre de service du ministère pour
l'ensemble de l'état pour le compte du
premier ministre qu'il s'agisse de
l'aide aux victimes à l'information de
ceux ci anna logistique de crise à la
fourniture d'équipements de protection à
la population nous appuyant sur les i et
soyez préfecture le ministère de
l'intérieur de renforcer ces instruments
notamment à destination des autres
ministères c'est ce qu'il a fait à
d'exception d'éducation nationale et de
la santé il a été le ministère qui a
fournit notamment les masques et à
certain nombre d'éléments dont l'état
avait besoin au début de cette crise
sanitaire
voilà ce que j'ai à dire mesdames et
messieurs les les sénateurs en en
partageant ces éléments de réflexion et
en m'excusant si je me frustre un peu la
commission ne répondant pas forcément à
toutes les questions notamment du
déroulement de la crise avant mon
arrivée mais je suis certain que je vais
pouvoir apporter avec les directeurs qui
m'accompagne ses réponses et vous dire
qu'évidemment nous sommes à votre
disposition pour de la formation
complémentaire tout à fait merci
monsieur le ministre je passe la parole
à bernard jomier à porter merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre exposé préliminaire a
effectivement l'intérêt de vous entendre
n'est évidemment pas liés à la gestion
du début de crise n'était pas en
fonction à ce moment là mais plus à
votre fonction institutionnelle vous
êtes mise intérieure actuellement est le
regard que le ministère de l'intérieur
de façon plus générale porte sur
l'organisation de la réponse à la crise
alors j'aurai une question à vous poser
on va dire actuelle pour commencer par
tard par celle là puisque voilà comme
celle vous concerne directement
nous sommes actuellement en difficulté
avec la mise en oeuvre de la stratégie
tester tracé isolé comme vous le savez
beaucoup d'interrogations on court sur
cette stratégie et sa mise en oeuvre
pardon or ce sont les préfets qui sont
chargés
au titre du code de la santé publique de
la distribution et du recueil des fiches
de traçabilité et donc j'aurais voulu
que vous nous apportiez des précisions
sur la façon dont ils organisent cette
responsabilité le deuxième point vous
avez dit ce que ce qu'on entend beaucoup
et ce qui est assez juste
nous sommes c'est que la crise repose
sur le couple maire préfère en tout cas
s'enrichit de cette collaboration entre
le maire et le préfet mais la question
se pose évidemment s'agissant d'une
crise de santé publique du lien avec les
institutions sanitaires donc il est tout
aussi évident il me semble pour tout le
monde qu'il faut dépasser ce couple et
que ce couple territorialisée on va dire
doit travailler avec les autres acteurs
donc on a vu des modes de fonctionnement
je vais pas revenir dessus très
différents selon les territoires souvent
pour des raisons humaines d'ailleurs des
facteurs humains
mais comment comment pensez-vous
l'institutionnalisation de ce lien entre
les élus locaux
le préfet qui est au regard du code de
la santé publique aussi à des
prérogatives de pilotage et les acteurs
les acteurs sanitaires les autorités de
santé voilà je m'en tiendrai à ces deux
questions je remercie
merci monsieur le ministre peut-être sur
le premier point
bien sûr ce sont les préfets vous avez
bien raison qu'ils sont ceux qui par la
loi à cordes mais le préfet n'est pas
que l'homme ou que la femme du ministre
l'intérieur par définition il est celui
qui agit au nom du gouvernement ait agi
pour chacun des ministres alors
évidemment le ministre de la santé a un
rôle particulier il gère les ars qui
sont des agences comme vous le savez
régional le préfet de département selon
la loi que vous évoquez lui à un échelon
départemental et donc c'est avec quick
avant-hier j'ai pris une circulaire pour
organiser la façon dont les choses a
fonctionné notamment sur les tests au
jour il ya plus d'un million de tests
qui ont été gérés par par le corps
préfectoral et cette circulaire qu'on
peut évidemment vous fournir permet de
organiser les choses puisque la
généralisation des tests tel que l'a
souhaité le gouvernement évidemment
poser un ensemble de questions
d'organisation et le ministre de la
santé aura particulièrement à voir cela
avec les représentants préfectoraux dans
chacun des départements
pour ce qui est
finalement le rapport entre le maire
préfet ou le nouveau couple les nouveaux
couples qu'on doit installer pour que
les choses aillent pour le mieux il est
évident que le rapport au maire préfet a
été d'abord je crois
extrêmement efficace pour l'échangé
d'informations au début de la crise
alors d'abord du confinement des règles
de conte de fées est appliquée puis du
déconfinement singulièrement ceux des
services publics municipaux que gérait
les maires indépendamment du rapport
politique que pouvait gérer un maire
avec des prêts faits et comme le préfet
de département je crois sont ceux son
travail premier d'ailleurs nous des
relations particulier temps avec
l'association départementale des maires
qu'avec les maires eux mêmes c'était une
bonne chose de le faire au niveau
politique comme comme au niveau
organisationnel la relation préfet ars
si je comprends bien votre votre
question est d je crois naturel dans
bien des cas à la difficulté mais
peut-être que votre commission
l'évoquera dans ses conclusions
que la rs par définition et régionales
et que le préfet qui arrange en charge
la gestion de crise des départementales
les préfets de région
s'ils ont pu être informés et s'ils sont
informés parce qu'en général ils sont
aussi t'as pas en général ils sont
préfet du département le plus important
c'est bien à ce titre de préfet de
département plus importants qui ont été
consultés n'ont pas autant préfet de
région il n'y a pas de compétences
reconnu ni affirmer des préfets de
région dans la gestion de crise
c'est soit les préfets de zone qui était
concernée soit plus singulièrement les
préfets de département a donc peut-être
que la difficulté d'organisation qui ne
tient pas au ministère à des combats
administratif aux technocrates ico des
luttes de pouvoir a été ou est le fait
qu'il ya des échelons départementaux où
il ya un peu de contacts départemental
de la rs avec le préfet sont pas tous
aussi le présent dans chacun des
départements et avec en revanche un
échelon régional pour la rs et il s'agit
donc évidemment sans doute de réfléchir
à cette meilleure articulation du fait
de compétences qui ne sont pas
contradictoires il s'agit bien au préfet
de gérer la gestion de crise avec des
administrateurs qui relève de la rs et
qui doivent éclairer les décisions
effectivement du corps préfectoral mais
il ya une différence d'échelon qui sans
doute a pu ici ou là pause et on l'a vu
tout lu sur nos territoires je suis élu
local moi même j'ai été maire pendant
cette crise se pose est donc le rôle
prédominant de l'assurance maladie pour
un traçabilité des cales contact et le
lien dumisa santé avec les préfets comme
la difficulté je trouve première puisque
c'était votre question principale du
lien entre préfets ars c'était une
question des jetons territoriale de
pareilles porter les réponses que vous
attendez oui merci monsieur réunissent
juste une précision sur votre réponse
précédente
antérieurement à la circulaire que je
n'ai pas vu mais que certainement on en
la présence bientôt vous avez signé
avant-hier si j'ai bien compris il n'y
avait pas de texte précis organisant le
recueil des des fiches de traçabilité la
mise en oeuvre du processus de
traçabilité où il y avait quelques
textes antérieurs sur lequel a été mise
en oeuvre ce que me dit le secrétaire
général c'est que les préfets un texte
donc on pourrait vous pour dire qu'il
prévoyait la mer d'hébergement des cas
contacts mais pas la traçabilité d'être
que vous l'évoquez qui relevait
l'assurance maladie
l'ag l'administration française c'était
l'assurance maladie noté sur le
programme précis mais des préfets n'est
pas disposition de demandes de la part
du gouvernement précise sur ce point est
la vôtre directive votre circulaire
pardon est clair exactement où vous
voulez fournir d'ailleurs ouais merci
important la séance le président merci
sylvie vermeillet merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
reviens sur le fonctionnement ars près
faits même si vous n'êtes en fonction
que depuis le 6 juillet et de vous tout
de même en fait qu'il y ait eu des
dysfonctionnements sur certains
territoires
alors on a des exemples de très bon
fonctionnement au cours de la commission
denquête on on s'est aperçu qu'il y
avait des heureusement beaucoup
d'endroits où il fallait se féliciter de
2,2 ce fonctionnement mais à d'autres
endroits il ya quand même eu des des
fonctionnements assez dommageable donc
vous avez dit à l'instant que il
s'agissait d'y réfléchir
est ce que quand même vous avez déjà
pris des dispositions pour pour
clarifier le fonctionnement
et puis une deuxième question le premier
ministre a indiqué que les plans de
confinement territoriaux et globaux
étaient prêts est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire comment il serait déclinée
localement
merci monsieur le ministre ce deuxième
point madame madame la sénatrice assez
simplement les préfets notamment parce
que des décrets n'ont prévu et décrets
sont possibles parce que le parlement
l'a souhaité ont la responsabilité dans
le cadre défini par la législation et
par le décret en question de prendre des
décisions qui leur permettent de pouvoir
mettre en place et blanc territorialisée
que souhaite le premier ministre il
suffit d'avoir vu ce qu'ont décidé les
préfets du bureau de la préfecture ont
très récemment pour voir que le
ministère de l'intérieur avec s'était
largement je pense que c'est plus proche
important pour une bonne gestion de
crise surtout quand on veut par confiner
généralement pour s'adapter aux
territoires et validons par par
définition ce que nous proposent les
préfets de la république du moment que
cela respecte évidemment les le cadre
légal et réglementaire que nous leur
avons fixé
donc les plantes territorialisées eh
bien ce sont les préfet qu'il est qu'il
est qu'ils les prennent
il nous avons des échanges alors très
souvent autour du préfet robin qui vous
savez celui qui travaille dans la
cellule interministérielle et peut
renseigner les préfets lorsqu'ils ont
des questions mais ils sont en
responsabilité prennent à la
responsabilité
évidemment de leurs de leurs
propositions et de leurs actes
réglementaires sur le sur le premier
point je vais vous répéter ce que j'ai
dit moi je vais effectivement je suis en
poste depuis le 6 juillet je n'ai pas eu
d'ailleurs dans mon département lui à
koné de dysfonctionnements à ma
connaissance pourtant je gérais une des
villes les plus importantes à deuxième
ville la plus importante du département
je crois que s'il ya eu des difficultés
de compréhension
elles sont du fait de cette
territorialisation mais des textes sont
clairs c'est bien le préfet qui à la
veille et la gestion de crise et puis il
est aidé par la rs
et si jamais il devait y avoir des
dysfonctionnements particulier je suis
certain que c'est votre commission qui
sera les soulever c'est vrai parce que
l'évolution est récente
ces territoires où c'est le préfet qui
donne les mesures qui vont être adaptées
au territoire et à la population
a contrario dans quelques mois de crise
précédent où les directives étaient
vraiment nationaliser qui pouvaient
poser un certain nombre de problèmes
effectivement donc là une vraie
adaptation de terrain qui est maintenant
visible
si je perds les deux femmes tautologie
mais ce président en répondant à votre
interpellation quand le confinement
était généralisé par définition les
préfets ont eu peu de marge de manoeuvre
en plus ce qu'ils étaient généralisées
depuis que nous avons choisie sous la
stratégie du premier ministre dans la
deuxième phase on va dire de ne pas re
confiné mais de pouvoir adapter de
freiner la propagation du virus il
apparaît c'est normal que ce soit le
préfet de département qui dans un cadre
légal et réglementaire défini
nationalement prennent des décisions
déconcentrer ça nous est d'ailleurs
parfois reprocher ça a été le cas à
l'assemblée nationale location
gouvernement cette semaine je crois que
le premier ce qu'il a répondu merci
catherine des roches oui merci président
merci mme
monsieur le ministre on a bien compris
que dans la rue organisation du système
et aidants larchitecture de gestion de
crise le retour d'expérience n'était pas
totalement fait là on est dans des
ajustements et vous avez évoqué quelques
pistes mais sans plus les détails et
donc je fais pas trop insister dessus
simplement par rapport aux places des
savoirs commencer à articuler la place
des préfets de zone par rapport aux
préfets préfets de région ou préfet de
département on a vu ça a été dit déjà
des relations très bonne entre à erez
préfet de région et préfet
départementaux mais il y avait quand
même parfois dans certains cas cette
notion ou la rs10 aime moi mon patron
c'est pas le préfet donc comment on va
résoudre cela on le fera dans l'avenir
j'avais une deuxième question qui
correspond aux transports alors nous
sommes allés avec la commission denquête
lundi après midi à roissy on entendait
beaucoup de choses sur l'arrivée des
passagers venant de deux pays dits
écarlate à roissy pour voir certains
nous disaient mais en fait les fiches
sont remplies elles ne servent à rien il
ne se passe rien non on a vu qu'ils se
passait en effet un circuit qu'on a bien
qu'on a bien identifié avec mes
collègues sylvie vermeillet martin
évrier victoire jasmin en effet des gens
qui arrivaient de ces pays dits écarlate
qui suivait s'il n'avait pas le test à
un circuit pour arriver jusqu'aux zones
de test avec peut-être deux bémols c'est
celui sur les fiches de traçabilité
d'ailleurs c'était un peu ce qu'ils
avaient fait les un peu d d expression
télévisuelle avec les réserves que l'on
met sur ces expressions disant moi j'ai
rempli une fiche on me l'a jamais
demandé et autres donc ça sert à rien ce
qu'on a vu néanmoins c'est que en règle
générale les friches été remplies elles
étaient recueillies par les compagnies
aérienne ensuite stockés au niveau de
l'aéroport et ensuite la grèce en cas de
besoin
il avait lui seul la possibilité des
raisons de confidentialité de les
récupérer
néanmoins ma question porte sur pourquoi
ne pas avoir utilisé alors il peut-être
ces petits os protection des données les
données du pnr qui recueille en effet
les noms des passagers avec beaucoup de
renseignements ci aurait été peut-être
plus simple que ce système de deux
fiches telles qu'elles sont actuellement
utilisés et le deuxième bémol c'est
certes les gens sont testés puis s'ils
n'ont pas eu tester mais comme c'était
ce sont pour la plupart du temps des
français résidents français ou des
personnes qui viennent pour ces pays là
avec une autorisation de de séjourner en
france ils repartent comme tout français
qui se fait tester en ayant un résultat
de deux tests différer ce qui est
d'ailleurs actuellement là la vraie
question c'est celui en effet de la
rapidité avoir la réponse qui fait que
la protection ou du fait de la non
contamination du virus on retrouve sans
retrouve diminué mais bon ça dépend
vraisemblablement pas de votre ministère
ce qu'on avait vu au début de la crise
on posera la question ministre qu'elle
testait nerfs enfin la ministre et ses
nerfs ce qu'on avait vu au début c'était
quand même un manque de protection
globale soignants mais aussi des forces
de l'ordre est-ce qu actuellement les
forces de l'ordre sont équipés en
protection par rapport aux missions qui
leur sont confiées puisqu'on est en plus
dans une période où le virus recommence
à circuler et plus dernier point mais
sans doute que ça ne dépend pas de vous
non plus c'était le relatif échec de ce
top cow vide c'est monsieur le ministre
merci gt2 commencé par répondre par des
dernières occasions sur le dernier point
vous avez évoqué le fait que ça ne
dépendait pas de moi je ne saurais dire
mieux sur le troisième point qui était
finalement les forces de l'ordre alors
le mon prédécesseur que vous aller
auditionner pour vous répondre mais moi
ce que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment il y assez de masques pour
les forces de l'ordre qui interviennent
chaque jour sur le territoire
ça me permet d'être de dire et donner
quelques
la représentation nationale il ya eu
vote et un million deux cent mille
personnes qui ont été contrôlées pendant
tout le confinement et 1,3 million de
personnes qui ont été verbalisés toute
force de notre confondues 1 police
nationale la gendarmerie et police
municipale et que depuis le
déconfinement 1044 1929 verbalise
verbalisation si on s'arrête toutes
sources confondues au 15 septembre pour
qu'ils ont effectivement été présent de
façon importante
je voudrais quand même dire que à ma
connaissance le ministère de l'intérieur
n'a pas manqué de masques pour les
forces de l'ordre puisqu'on a eu 1,1
million de masques qui étaient
disponibles notamment avec au début de
la crise du corona virus les masques
dans chaque voiture qui n'était pas
apporté de façon généralisée c'est
peut-être ce que vous souhaitiez le dire
et depuis la mi-avril 10 millions de
masques sont arrivés et il ya désormais
assez de masques effectivement pour
répondre à des besoins des forces de
l'ordre qui travaillent chaque jour et
chaque nuit sur sur la sécurité publique
de nos concitoyens sur la question des
données pnr
j'oserais dire sans passer à la
représentation nationale qu'il s'agit
d'un dispositif législatif qui prévoit
explicitement pas que ce ne soit utilisé
à des fins sanitaires autre que
sécuritaire donc si devenir des
modifications elle relève
elle relève du parlement et dans un
contexte sans doute sauvé par l'union
européenne et son droit direct donc
l'utilisation des données de sécurité de
passagers pour l'utiliser à des fins
internes ne n'est pas autorisé
évidemment par le par le parlement et
sur le premier point d'abord je voudrais
redire que il ya peut-être des habitudes
administratives et de discussions entre
les préfets de région et les agressent
mais dans la gestion de crise et même
préfet de département qui est en
responsabilité des préfets des zones ne
sont en revanche essentiel pour la
coordination des moyens
donc ça a été le cas pour la
distribution par exemple des masques ou
le partage d'informations mais c'est un
temps de près en tant que préfet de zone
et qu'ils l'ont fait pas en tant que
préfet de région et c'est bien les
préfets de département qui était
l'interlocuteur des drs j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre sur les peut-être
difficulté territoriales que cela
pouvait engendrer même si je pense pas
que cela ça l'a été
son importante sur le sol national
pendant la crise catherine des roches
sur la protection des forces de l'ordre
on verra ça avec l'ancien ministre
castaner n'a pas forcément les mêmes les
mêmes éléments et est ce que les
personnels sont régulièrement testé est
ce qu'on en a à partir de puits consenti
le tester
car moi je sais que je sais depuis que
je suis ministre de l'intérieur et que
j'ai eu à connaître des cas après dix
heures de discussions des récupérations
syndicale j'en ai parlé avec eux
l'ancien puis le nouveau secrétaire
général de l'oci directeur général de la
police nationale et directeur de
gendarmerie nationale si quelqu'un
venait à être positifs au cours de la
vie russe nous avons une médecine
évidemment de prévention en médecine du
travail
la fonction publique c'était d'ailleurs
le cas dans les anciennes fonctions on a
eu à gérer les douaniers les agents de
la direction générale des finances
publiques et de nous conformons
évidemment aux prescriptions des
médecins et edéa grèce lorsque c'est le
lorsque c'est le cas on teste lorsque
cela est demandé par les par le par les
médecins l'ensemble des hommes une
brigade et il nous arrive parfois de la
fermer si jamais le considérons qu'il
fallait mettre en quarantaine en
septaine comme on dit désormais en 14 n
les agents et nous faisons comme chaque
employé je crois le fait comme le sénat
doit le faire pour ces agents publics
merci j'aime le rapporteur traite
je vais passer aux questions de vos
questions de nos commissaires
j'ai déjà cinq inscriptions
roger karoutchi
j'ai le président monsieur le ministre
le chef de l'état nous a dit au mois de
mars c'est la guerre quand on fait la
guerre
on a un cabinet de pierre on a un chef
d'état major
ce fut le brillant main général foch
puis le moins brillant général gamelin
mais on a un peu le sentiment qu'il ya
une identification pour donner confiance
aux populations pour donner le sentiment
que les choses sont gérées de manière
coordonnée pour restaurer un peu le
crédit de la parole publique
pendant la crise or pas revenir là
dessus vous n'était pas ministre de
l'intérieur mais enfin c'est vrai qu'on
a eu beaucoup le sentiment des errements
sur les masques sur les tests étaient là
après il ya une période d'accalmie
mais nous voilà depuis trois semaines un
mois avec une reprise sensible du nombre
de cas qui inquiètent légitimement les
français et dans cette période
d'inquiétude
on a un peu le sentiment que la parole
publique face à la crise sanitaire
elle est loin d'être uniforme un coup
c'est mise de la santé un coup c'est le
premier ministre
un coup c'est le directeur général de la
santé un coup c'est tel ou tel comité
scientifique
tout ça est un peu désordonné et ne
contribue pas à calmer le jeu alors vous
avez décidé enfin le gouvernement a
décidé d'accélérer d'accentuer le rôle
préfet maire et c'est une bonne chose
parce que les mères on joue un rôle
essentiel
pendant la crise du printemps je dirais
presque un rôle primordial pour
compenser les faiblesses souvent de
l'état mais ça contribue à dire il ya
plus des mesures uniques je veux dire un
exemple d'abord et je poserai la
question qui conclut on dit c'est au
préfet de décider
résultat le préfet à marseille le préfet
à bordeaux prend des décisions ou
ailleurs ou à strasbourg ou à lille
d'ailleurs j'ai vus comme des décisions
sur un certain nombre d'activités dans
les villes le préfet d'île de france
pour des raisons autres n'en prend pas
on se dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe la
métropole du grand paris
n'a pas de circulation du virus aussi
forte qu'à bordeaux qu'à marseille
naturellement et qu'il faut se le faire
en concertation avec les élus mais on a
un peu le sentiment que c'est parfois
deux poids deux mesures et ça ne donne
pas forcément une confiance absolue
parce que c'est comme ça on voit bien et
c'est pas spécifique à paris dans les
communes de banlieue aussi on autorise
l'extension des terrasses on peut pas
dire que partout le respect des
distances ou ou des mesures sanitaires
soient respectés c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire et on voit pas beaucoup de
sanctions
et ça crée un malaise dans la population
qui est dans la crainte cette épidémie
qui reprend est ce que au delà de tout
ça vous n'avez pas le sentiment que au
delà du lien préfet maire il faudrait
pas surtout si la crise sanitaire devait
s'accentuer
et si avant qu'on arrive au confinement
je l'espère il faudrait pas trouver une
solution un peu différente pour que la
parole de l'état sur la gestion de la
crise soit une parole plus unifiée et
elle n'est pas forcément je le dis
franchement c'est pas du tout de ma part
d'une réserve à l'égard de monsieur vers
ans elle n'est pas forcément sur le
ministre de la santé
on peut choisir différemment mais qu'il
y ait une unité de politique même si les
préfets peuvent ensuite modulée en
fonction des conditions locales et qu'il
y est surtout une unité de la parole
publique sur la gestion de la crise ça
manque cruellement
et ça risque de manquer dans les
semaines qui viennent cruellement
merci olivier henno oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le ministre je vais profiter de vos
responsabilités passées en tant que
ministre qui avait une responsabilité
vis-à-vis des douanes et est maire d'une
ville frontalière et puis aussi
aujourd'hui ministre de l'intérieur pour
vous interroger sur un sujet qui m'est
cher celui de la coordination entre les
différents pays européens
et puis des échanges avec les homologues
européens
parce que parfois et je me fais un peu
l'avocat des familles qui avaient des
personnes fragiles puisque dans le nord
c'est assez fréquent des personnes
fragiles personnes âgées aux personnes
handicapées qui étaient dans des maisons
d'hébergement en belgique et qui ont eu
quelques fois à souffrir à la fois d'une
absence de réciprocité un un défaut
quelquefois de d'information enfin une
visibilité et donc de vous interroger
pour savoir si vous voyez des des pistes
d'amélioration dans la gouvernance ou
dans les échanges avec les pays
frontaliers où les pays européens qui
nous entourent je vous remercie
merci angèle préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre alors je
vais avoir des questions très concrètes
au sujet des verbalisations est ce que
il y à une évolution qui verbalisent qui
est verbalisé dans quelles circonstances
est ce que vous pouvez nous donner une
image de ce que vous savez pour le
moment sur ces verbalisations et est
également nous dire ce qui se passe dans
les pays limitrophes d'une autre moeurs
voilà pour la première salle chez le
ministre vous avez la parole
peut-être pour répondre monsieur
président au ministre karoutchi en
métaux nantes le sénat souhaite que
l'état soit encore plus jacobin je n'ai
pas compris ça de son groupe politique
notamment depuis trois ans mais
cependant quand on est jacobins il faut
des girondins quand on est girondins
faut être jacobins très bien mais ça ne
m'étonne pas de la culture politique de
je connais de de l'agriculture pratique
que je connais de miss karoutchi ça ne
m'étonne pas il reste fidèle et
peut-être tant mieux il le sait il le
sait ne partageons une certaine identité
de vues comme on aurait dit bon
indépendamment de cette légère
provocation mais qui traduit quand même
je crois le fond de la pensée
je voudrais lui dire que d'abord il n'ya
pas des résultats de ce que nous en
connaissons de circulation du virus
partout pareil sur le territoire
national et les français ne
comprendraient justement pas ne couvre
ajustements page élire au cas
particulier de l'île de france c'est ces
différences n'ont apprécié par le
terrain deuxièmement monsieur le
ministre si je fume parler de vous
corriger ce n'est pas le préfet
d'ile-de-france qui peut prendre des
dispositions pour ce corps une fois il
n'est certes d'abord par le préfet de
paris puisqu'il ya préfet de police pour
les questions de sécurité comme vous le
savez mais il est par ailleurs en aucun
cas responsable des questions de
coordination d'âgés sont crise puisque
comme je l'expliquais dans des propos
liminaires
c'est évidemment le préfet du
département le préfet de police de paris
a pris des dispositions qui n'existe pas
sur d'autres territoires français le
port du masque obligatoire partout à
paris
c'est une disposition qui n'existe pas
dans d'autres territoires
voilà donc il a pris il a pris des
dispositions
il appartient à chaque préfet de prendre
ses dispositions une pochette police de
paris à ma connaissance n'a pas accordé
de dérogation que d'autres préféreront
un corner donc vous pouvez peut-être
être gênés par la polyphonie la
polyphonie qui n'est pas une cacophonie
des représentants de l'état parce qu'ils
s'adaptent aux territoires je pense que
c'est ce que demande la haute assemblée
dans sa volonté forte me semble-t-il
d'écouter les territoires si j'ai bien
compris les propos du président
d'archers depuis que je suis ministre de
la république
j'aurais quand même souligner puisque je
trouve que le réquisitoire du ministre
karoutchi tout en est tout en étant bien
bien bien précis et pour le moins un peu
dur c'est une crise qui dure depuis neuf
mois
il n'y a pas d'équivalent sauve guerre
mondiale évidemment une acidité gamelin
et eiffage personnellement je les ai pas
connu mais il a cité il a cité il y là
et la cité il est la cité il a cité aidé
à citer des guerres mondiales mais c'est
qu'à part les guerres mondiales l'état
n'a pas eu à coeur une gestion de crise
de cette durée de 9 mois qui va sans
doute continuer par ailleurs et je pense
qu'on peut quand même mettre ça du côté
de la difficulté des agents de l'état
d'eux est mort cette crise sanitaire et
elle est à proprement parler inédite
nous n'avons pas connu à l'échelle d'un
homme me semble-t-il une crise sanitaire
qui engendrait autant de difficultés
bien sûr administratives et d'ordre
public d'accompagnement de santé de
gestion elle est mondiale
ça n'est jamais arrivé y compris dans
les guerres mondiales n'était pas tout à
fait celle ci était de semaine d'une
manière une sorte de mondialisation de
la crise et puis enfin c'est à dire est
que nous ne connaissions pas d'ailleurs
que nous connaissons d'ailleurs toujours
difficilement
donc je crois que il jugé avec les yeux
d'aujourd'hui ce qui est arrivé il ya
quelques mois
en tout cas c'est mon opinion
personnelle si le président me permets
de l'évoquer mais n'est pas n'est pas la
meilleure des choses pour pouvoir
comprendre de l'action de l'état me
semble-t-il et notamment des des
responsables qui ont essayé de le servir
monsieur le sénateur raynaud a raison de
souligner la difficulté frontalière avec
la belgique nous partageons des baux
département du nord en commun mais c'est
le cas aussi d'autres départements de
nos frontières et notamment des
questions des personnes vulnérables il
ya aussi vous savez les rapprochements
amoureux comme on les a dit il beaucoup
je sais qu'ici les sénateurs
représentent aussi des français de
l'étranger
c'est souvent au souligné bah je serais
pour la suite des événements je crois
que le mieux c'est de faire ce qu'on a
su faire à mon avis deuxième partie de
la crise qui était de se parler dans un
cadre européen et puis ensuite de se
parler lorsqu'on fermés ou réouvrait ou
permettait un certain nombre de passages
entre eux entre autres pays
quand je suis arrivé au ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai pris contact avec no no
no no pays ami de l'espagne de l'italie
notamment et en leur rappelant et temps
est évidemment parfaitement d'accord en
allemagne également pardon que si jamais
nous devions ce qui n'est absolument pas
le cas aujourd'hui
mais imaginer quelque chose qui
ressemblait en tout cas une restriction
de passage tel que nous l'avons connu
dans les crises précédentes que cela se
fasse sous l'égide et sous la
coordination de l'union européenne est
évidemment en discutant en se parlant et
en essayant d'aider les populations qui
ont des intérêts de vie qui sont
évidemment qui sont évidemment
extrêmement important pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas la beauté la beauté
d'une heure il ya évidemment ni fleuve
nini montagne entre entre nos deux pays
notre belgique et la france
les habitudes de vie sont extrêmement
importants pour transfrontalier que pour
évidemment les personnes notamment des
caps et où vit comme l'a évoqué le
sénateur et je ne peux que prendre son
poing et ça peut faire partie des
réflexions pour demain pour la gestion
d'une autre crise qui viendrait à
arriver sur les verbalisations jeu j'ai
du mal à comprendre tout à fait la
question d'un massacre je vais essayer
d'y répondre cependant puisque j'ai
donné le nombre total de verbalisation
aujourd'hui l'outil qu'ils utilisent et
c'est le procès verbal électronique que
de l'ensemble des agents de l'état qui
peuvent verbaliser gendarmes et
policiers et les polices municipales
lorsque les mères en eau et le
souhaitent
45000 verbalisation donc à peu près en
beauté miss et 135 euros
l'amande
nous n'avons pas particulièrement de
sociologie pour l'instant statistiques
sur ces verbalisations c'était la
question de la sénatrice
mais nous pourrions grâce à lanta y
fournir à la représentation nationale
même si nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui je
voudrais vraiment le dire à ma
connaissance peut-être des profiteurs
par département il faudrait peut-être
demandé au patron de l'en taille le
préfet fisc us un certain nombre
d'éléments statistiques que vous
souhaiteriez à voir et qui serait
d'ailleurs intéressant très certainement
mais pour l'instant je ne les je ne les
ai pas parce que j'ai moins comme retour
des verbalisations c'est effectivement
par département et par force qui des
gendarmes qui démolit station ce qui
nous éclairent sur la ruralité peut-être
et elle s'en trouvait même si vous savez
que les découpages des forces ne sont
pas toujours aussi évidente que ces deux
là ma faim ça donne une première
indication
je ne les ai pas mais je prépare faire
parvenir monsieur le président si la
vôtre commission le souhaitait merci un
mot simplement monsieur le ministre mais
les mesures européennes mais je crois
que entre le nord et le pas de calais et
la belgique maintenant il ya une mise en
quarantaine qui a été décidé par la
belgique pour ceux qui venaient de
france non gelée cru avoir cette
information hier pour les départements
du nord et du pas de calais la belgique
a décidé n'omettant en quarantaine alors
leur quarantaine je ne sais pas si elle
dure 14 ou sept jours mais il me semble
utile que la décision a été élu ni la
terre me semble-t-il mais vous avez plus
de pression et un deuxième point si vous
permettez
on n'est pas là pour écrire réécrire
l'histoire à notre commission denquête
c'est bien analyser l'histoire pour en
tirer un certain nombre de conséquences
voire bien sûr ce qui a bien été et
aussi là où ça pue moins bien se passer
de façon à pouvoir en tirer les
conséquences sans procès d'intention me
semble-t-il c'est simplement sur le sol
deux premiers points avec le 2e
n'appelle pas pour moi de commentaire
évidemment je jeu la belgique comme
l'allemagne ou comme d'autres pays ont
procédé à kehl et des lieux de
circulation du virus
d'abord parce que nous communiquions en
transparence sur ces difficultés il en
tirera des conclusions pour leur
territoire national moi je te ce que je
veux dire c'est que ce virus il connaît
évidemment pardon de le redire pas de
frontières
et que l'un peut-être line deneault de
nos nos difficultés c'est évidemment de
comprendre ce qui se passe à l'échelon
départemental on a évoqué le préfet et
la circulation de virus dans cet échelon
départemental et c'est pas la même chose
virus le sénateur hainaut le le sait ne
circule pas de la même manière dans la
métropole lilloise plus qu'il circule
très vite dans la métropole lilloise
mois le département du nord et dans le
plus grand de france et pour des raisons
révolutionnaire accompagnant la belgique
- fourmies que que dans la métropole
tout simplement nos règles
départementale font que le préfet prend
des mesures départemental et nos amis
belges ont manifestement mis en place
effectivement des mesures de protection
elle n'empêche cependant pas les
échanges de ce que j'en sais de ma vie
tourquennoise avec la belgique
merci disions alors marie pierre de la
gontrie
merci président j'aurai deux questions à
poser au ministre de l'intérieur
la première le concerne en tant que chef
d'administration et je ne mélange pas le
fait qu'il n'ait pas été en charge
depuis le début de cette crise du
ministère de l'intérieur
mais je voudrais rappeler que votre
prédécesseur devant l'assemblée
nationale le 9 avril avait indiqué qu'il
souhaitait que le coc u19 sont inscrits
au tableau des maladies professionnelles
et que le lien entre la fiction et leurs
services automatiquement présumé pour
les agents dès lors qu'il était établi
qu'ils ont assuré une mission au contact
du public durant l'état d'urgence
sanitaire
évidemment ce point portait sur les
forces de l'ordre car nous nous
rappelons dès le début du confinement
nous ne pouvions sortir que une heure
hors de chez nous et muni d'une
attestation et les forces de l'ordre
étaient mobilisés de manière très
intense pour faire en sorte que tout ça
se déroule dans les meilleures
conditions et christophe castaner
indiqué vous avoir saisi le 7 avril sur
ce point pour cette reconnaissance se
traduisent au plus vite
un décret est paru il ya quelques jours
le 14
je mets de côté le fait que itunes
ils limitent aux infections
respiratoires aiguës avec l'assistance
avec assistance respiratoire ou le décès
bien évidemment donc il écartait la
question de la présomption mais surtout
les toute autre prise les soignants ne
sont plus concernés donc j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure mais nous aurons
l'occasion de revenir venir est que le
ministre castaner que les masques n'ont
jamais manqué enfin je résume votre
propre aux maîtres de manière un peu
sommaire ce n'est pas les témoignages
qui circulent mais vous n'étiez pas en
charge donc je n'y reviens pas mais donc
pas question et avez vous l'intention de
prendre la mesure qui avait été annoncé
est très attendue par les forces de
l'ordre qui parmi ceux que l'on appelait
en première ligne en deuxième ligne on
était très très mobilisé dans des
conditions père venir mais je crois
qu'on leur disait à l'époque lorsqu'il
faisait un contrôle à l'extérieur ils
n'avaient pas porter de masque dès lors
qu'il constatait que la personne ne
portait pas de virus ce qui était quand
même assez audacieux c'est donc ma
première question ma deuxième question
et vous verrez que je suis très précises
afin que vous ne puissiez pas dire que
je procède à une caricature malhonnête
je souhaiterais revenir sur la décision
prise par le préfet du pas de calais
concernant la distribution de repas à
calais vous avez rencontré la maire de
calais et quelques heures plus tard le
lendemain le préfet a pris un arrêté
pour interdire la distribution de repas
en centre ville par toute autre
association que l'association agréé qui
s'appelle la vie active afin que le
centre ville c'est comme ça qu'ils aient
compris soit ne soit plus le théâtre
semble utile de rassemblement qui était
inopportun il faut rappeler peut-être
nos collègues ne le savent pas qu'elle
n'arrêtait analogue avait été pris par
la mère il ya environ trois ans qui lui
même avait été arrêté si je me permets
d'y revenir c'est qu'il parlait lors de
la suspension de six ministres hâtif
avait noté la teinte manifestement
illicite aux droits des personnes
concernées l'obstacle à la satisfaction
des besoins élémentaires vitaux de ne
pas subir de traitement inhumain et
dégradant prévu à l'article 3 de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme donc ma question est la suivante
viactive 10 indique elle même distribué
de 1000 à 1200 repas par jour or il y a
environ 2000 personnes sur site la vie
active dix ans elle même que l
elle fournit guillemets la majorité des
migrants
donc ma question est la suivante comment
concevez-vous de concilier je mets de
côté mon jugement
j'en veux dire politique sur le sujet ce
n'est pas l'objet mais comment en tant
que ministre de l'intérieur
pouvez-vous concilier votre rôle de
défenseur du respect de l'ordre public
je comprends que c'est l'objet de cet
arrêté et les droits humains pour
résumer tels qu'ils ont été rappelés par
le tribunal administratif de lille
et vous l'avez noté je mets de côté mon
avis personnel ce n'est pas l'objet se
séparent et et fait l'objet d'une
procédure judiciaire
mais on voit qu'il y a quand même une
difficulté dans ce que vous avez
souhaité et donc c'est là dessus que je
souhaiterais vous interrogez j'espère
que vous noterez que ce n'est pas une
caricature malhonnête
merci victoire jasmin oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre il a été
décidé que pour se rendre dans certains
territoires particulièrement les
outre-mer et il fait faire un test de
moins de 72 heures il se trouve qu'il y
a pour un problème aujourd'hui parce que
les laboratoires sont sous tension ou
bien ils sont des poèmes de réactifs aux
dents en tout cas les délais de rendu
des résultats sont quelquefois très
important et il ya les personnes qui
malheureusement on perd 10 des billets
d'avion tout simplement parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas des billets qu'ils
pouvaient modifier et en même temps on
constate qu'il ya certains laboratoires
d'analysés de biologie médicale qui pour
payer 100 euros 100 euros jeudi pour
obtenir les résultats dans les délais
impartis
je vous remercie merci martin lévriers
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre il ya une petite musique qui
courent souvent et depuis longtemps dans
la presse un peu partout sur jeu
l'autorité de l'état et sur une petite
musique disant que les tout n'est jamais
vraiment clair moi j'ai vu que quand à
paris a été décidée le port du masque
obligatoire
les parisiens n'ont vraiment respecté et
je suis assez fier de voir que c'est
compris et respecté globalement
simplement reste selon moi un petit
problème je les ai vus en particulier
hier soir en me promenant des jeunes la
nuit en particulier qui se réunit je
pense aux invalides hier soir où il y
avait au moins 300 ou 400 jeunes très
gentil et mais très peu masqué or on
sait tous qu'ils sont asymptomatiques
qu'ils ont peut-être besoin qu'on leur
rappelle la loi donc je me demandais ce
qu'il faudrait pas avoir des opérations
bienveillante mais ferme pour leur
rappeler qu'ils peuvent mettre les
autres en danger sans oublier à tout
moment enfin voir des peut-être des
mesures spécifiques pour cette
population là
sans rentrer dans la dans la
contravention systématique merci
beaucoup merci avant de vous passer la
parole bien entendu monsieur unis de
l'intérieur moi j'avais une question à
laquelle supplémentaire vous pourrez
peut-être répondre par écrit parce que
peut-être que elle relève peut-être
d'ailleurs plus puisque c'est une
période transitoire de votre
prédécesseur mais on a posé des
questions sur les réquisitions le masque
qui avait été fait et par le préfet et
on voulait en savoir combien avaient été
faites qu'elles avaient été les les
conséquences et le ministère de la santé
nous renvoie sur le ministère de l'
intérêt puisque ce sont les préfets qui
ont pris les mesures de réquisition vous
souvenez sur certains territoires nous
en tout cas on a vécu ça dans dans le
grand-est savez pose un certain nombre
de problèmes donc on voulait avoir un
retour un petit peu d'expérience ses
taux mais c'est important de le faire en
cas de de rebond de 2,2 de l'épidémie
sur ses réquisitions merci je vous passe
la parole
merci monsieur le président pour
répandre la sénatrice
sur à la fois qu'elle est et sur le la
maladie professionnelle pour les agents
du ministère de l'intérieur
lorsque le ministre de l'intérieur qui
savent castadère m'avait interpellé il
l'avait effectivement dit me semble-t-il
un sommet national
ça fait juste il avait saisi le
ministère de la fonction publique c'est
à dire moi même alors vous saviez tous
même s'il n'est pas de délégation de
rethel c'était que weezy du sol ces
tests ethernet entraînements et traille
particulièrement sur la question la
fonction publique et nous avons instruit
avec olivier dussopt puisqu'ils sont été
particulièrement occupé les questions
qui ne concernait pas simplement mus à
l'intérieur mais des agents publics de
manière générale même si les forces de
l'ordre par le fait qu'ils étaient en
contact
chacun le comprend ne doivent pas être
défavorisés et ça reste toujours mon
opinion vis-à-vis d'autres agents
publics comme les agents qui relève du
ministère de la santé et dont vous avez
bien voulu rappeler que un décret a
reconnu pour eux des spécificités
particulières et donc on avait commencé
à travailler sur un mécanisme qui
permettait en effet de répondre à
l'interrogation de mise à l'intérieur
que j'aidais renouvelée en arrivant au
ministère de l'intérieur suite à une
réunion intersyndicale que j'ai
rencontrée la semaine d'après ma
nomination et je sais que madame de
montchanin termine le mécanisme pour
lequel nous avons travaillé et
incessamment sous peu m'a-t-on dit
puisque je devais interrogé il n'est pas
extrêmement montant aura l'occasion de
compléter les dispositions prévues à la
fois pour les soignants mais aussi pour
le privé puisqu'un décret du 4 septembre
est également paru mais pour fabre pour
jour à l'époque je travaillais avec
olivier dussopt pour l'ancien des agents
publics et j'ai renouvelé en tant que
ministre de l'intérieur
changeant ainsi de rôle mais à une
continuité de pensée de solidarité
gouvernementale pour les 1000 agents qui
était sous ma responsabilité
renouvelant ainsi la demande qui avait
été faite par mon prédécesseur à olivier
dussopt témoin même donc c'est au même
principe et notamment vous avez bien
voulu souligner je suis je suis souscrit
qu'il s'agit bien des formes avérée
notamment ceux qui ont contracté par
dont le coronavirus et qui on est et qui
ont effectivement le qui sont l'objet de
votre question quel est l'objet du
courriel adressé le ministre de
l'intérieur que j'ai donc redoubler même
de montchanin sur le sujet qu'elle est
d'abord je me permets de vous corriger
ou de vous complétez si vous le
permettez à la sénatrice lorsque madame
le maire de calais a utilisé son pouvoir
réglementaire pour empêcher la
distribution en centre-ville s'agit pas
de l'empêcher dans la ville de calais ce
que je lis beaucoup d'inexactitudes
sur ce point le très bon ministre hâtive
de lille a cassé cet arrêté sous le seul
prétexte mais il faut l'entendre que il
était pas du pouvoir réglementaire de
madame le maire de québec de prendre cet
arrêté est donc elle en a déduit que
lille était du pouvoir de l'autorité de
l'état
ils sont représentants l'occurrence le
préfet du pas de calais de prendre le
dit arrêtez donc j'ai compris qu'une
association présentée devant le tribunal
administratif
une protestation de cet arrêté nous
verrons bien ce que dira le tribunal
administratif de lille mais c'était sur
une question d'autorité réglementaire
que principalement cet arrêté avait
jadis étaient annulés
deuxièmement je voudrais souligner que
l'arrêté de monsieur le préfet du pas de
calais est circonscrit dans le temps et
les s'est construit sur un endroit
spécifique comme le prévoit le droit
administratif afin qu' il n'y ait pas
d'utilisation général abusif un excès de
pouvoir des représentants du pouvoir
réglementaire et donc il nous paraît
tout à fait pour des résurrections dans
non pas à une question politique c'est
d'ailleurs pas comme ça que vous avez
posé je l'entends bien mais parfois
c'est ce que je dis de l'interdiction de
distribuer des repas aux personnes
migrants dans le centre-ville de manière
générale par principe mais bien parce
que nous sommes particulièrement
désormais à ma connaissance pour la
médiatrice il ya 1500 c'est déjà
beaucoup
migrants dans le cas des c'est environ
60% d'ailleurs viennent de la belgique
pour pouvoir traverser on sait que
depuis napoléon
c'est plus facile de traverser par la
france et par boulogne-sur-mer et calais
et que que parce que par la belgique est
à la fois le fait qu' il y ait moins de
camions qui passent du côté britannique
que le bric si tu arrives avec des
dispositions qui vont sans doute
remettre en cause d'un certain nombre de
sujets que l'été était là et que l'été
comme chacun de ces dans la région des
autres français toujours un endroit où
la mer est calme et on peut davantage
passer lorsqu'on a envie de traverser
pour des raisons que l'humanitaire que
l'on peut tout à fait comprendre la
manche
il ya une difficulté particulière
d'ordre public mais aussi et c'est ce
que la maire de calais a voulu me
démontrer et je les écoutais de
possibilités de circulation du virus
dans la distribution de rue messager
bien de ça la sénatrice distribution de
rue deux des dix repas et donc le vous
évoquez les droits humains j'y suis
évidemment comme tous les humanistes et
comme tous les répliques extrêmement
sensible je m'intéresse évidemment en
droits humains des migrants que nous
accompagnons dont la lutte contre les
passeurs me semble être ailleurs
le premier devoir de l'état de lutter
contre l'exploitation des êtres humains
l'état mandate des associations comme
vous l'avez dit 2000 repas par jour sont
sont distribués l'hébergement est
systématique des migrants lorsque nous
intervenons pour les mettre à l'abri les
interventions des policiers ou des
gendarmes sont quasiment quotidiens pour
les aider à ne pas se noyer dans la
manche puisque des drames peuvent
évidemment arriver encore la semaine
dernière des policiers fin des gendarmes
en l'occurrence se sont jetés à l'eau
pour sauver des personnes des personnes
migrantes et ses droits humains ils sont
aussi les droits humains des la
population calaisienne qui vit moi je
vous encourage évidemment à vous y
rendre également des situations
extrêmement délicate surtout ces
derniers temps où l'accumulation du
nombre de migrants du fait de à la fois
du déconfinement mais aussi des
difficultés que nous avons avec nos amis
britanniques et enfin avec
l'accumulation des traversées par une
par mer calme si j'ose dire fait que les
choses n'étaient plus possibles travers
de calais d'où l'art était circonscrit
dans le temps dans un lieu
pour effectivement les distributions de
rues de repas évidemment toujours des
distributions de repas à calais qui ne
se font pas dans la rue en centre ville
mais bien au plus proche de là où les
migrants peuvent être ce qui n'est pas
toujours évident d'ailleurs de définir
et dans des conditions qui me paraissent
tout à fait conforme à ce que l'état a
toujours fait quels que soient les
gouvernements dans cette situation
particulière où on a toujours à l'essai
essayé d'allier fermeté comme le disait
le premier ministre cazeneuve et
humanité sur la question de l'outre-mer
je comprends tout à fait les difficultés
que vous évoquez de la sénatrice et on
peut être scandalisé de l'utilisation
cupide de notamment pour nos
compatriotes ultramarins et j'ai eu à
connaître parfois même à m'étonner
intervenir en tant que élus des
situations que vous que vous évoquez
nous l'état il met des moyens dans le
remboursement des tests à une question
évidemment de délai n'était pas toujours
compatibles avec eux parfois les
demandes où on prenait son avion pour
retourner dans les territoires
ultramarins
on a essayé au maximum à ma connaissance
d'améliorer les choses et votre
commission s'est rendue d'ailleurs à
l'aéroport de roissy je crois à la ville
professionnalisme le des agents qui
servait le ministère de l'intérieur
je ne peux qu'être d'accord avec votre
constat il appartient sans doute au
ministre des transports est émise la
santé d'évoquer plus avant une question
de rapport avec les laboratoires ou du
retour dans la continuité territoriale
des territoires nationaux ultramar à sur
finalement le l'invitation à la
bienveillance active du sénateur le
verrier
il n'a pas tort et je crois que ce
serait mentir si je vous disais qu'en
tant que chef d'administration les
agents ne sont pas tous les jours dans
l' hyper en tout cas c'est les consignes
que j'ai passé je suis mise intérieur
discussions avec tout le monde
pas simplement sur l'esplanade des
invalides mais dans tous les endroits où
et
les regroupements disons que les
abeilles dont au moins un avantage
d'être ouvert au vent mais j'ai géré un
été avec les préfets de soirée interdite
qui se sont quand même réunis chacun a
pu le constater au même moment ont
demandé aux patrons de discothèques ou
de restaurants de parfois de de rester
fermés d'intervenir
chacun a vu parfois même des images
alors si elles ont parfois fait scandale
mais elle était semble-t-il légitime
l'intervention à paris même dans des
reproductions de deux demi finales ou de
finale de deux matchs de football
genre agglutinés ou parfois vous savez
monsieur le sénateur je sais votre
question n'était pas que naïve c'est pas
parce que les forces de l'ordre explique
aux gens qui ne faut pas qu'ils se
regroupent gentiment qu'il écoutait
sagement obéissent à l'autorité du
représentant des forces de l'ordre
de temps en temps il faut savoir
verbalisées ou intervenir lorsque cela
est nécessaire cc c'est évidemment
peut-être un travail davantage encore
que nous le faisons aujourd'hui
peut-être j'entends votre j'entends
votre remarque
la consigne que j'ai donné c'est de
verbaliser évidemment lorsque c'était
nécessaire et deux au maximum discuter
avec un maximum de personnes pour que
chacun ait la responsabilité de ses
actes de ce point de vue je ne peux je
ne peux que relayer une nouvelle fois je
le redirai au monsieur le préfet de
police de paris de faire attention dans
les lieux de rassemblement qui nous
permette effectivement dû discuter au
maximum et que ce port du masque il est
absolument obligatoire à paris vous
aurez d'ailleurs constaté monsieur le
président qu on a simplifié pour les
parisiens la question parce que quand je
suis arrivé au ministère de l'intérieur
le préfet de police m'a présenté la
carte qui existaient de découpage dans
paris là où devait porter un masque que
l'on ne devait pas porter un masque il
faut avouer que ce n'est pas toujours
évident et donc pour la simplification
de tous on a décidé et des difficultés
les difficultés qu'on a qu'on a pu
remarquer de circulation du virus du
mois de juillet j'ai décidé d'accepter
la proposition du préfet de police de
paris dira la maire de paris a
accompagné cette décision et je le
remercie de m tout paris en port du
masque obligatoire afin de simplifier
les règles
enfin cela l'acquisition je ne connais
pas
monsieur le monsieur le président mais
soit mon prédécesseur pourra vous aider
à prendre soin on vous et à pouvoir bien
évidemment si vous me posez la question
par écrit si vous permettez je sais
qu'il n'est pas de coutume ne pas
répondre aux questions auxquelles on n'a
pas été on n'a pas été interrogé merci
beaucoup
puisque vous évoquez les douanes tout à
l'heure à vous à la fois vous même et et
sénateurs et nos jeux vous à dire à quel
point le ministre des douanes que j'ai
été induit parfois soutenir fortement
son administration qu a fait un travail
formidable dans cette période
extrêmement difficile pour ne pas
délivrer des masques qui à peine arrivé
souvent d'un seul extra français aurait
dû être sous la pression politique
souvent des locaux ou des du tout court
délivrer immédiatement sous prétexte que
les douaniers faisait leur travail de
vérification de cette marchandise comme
toute autre marchandise et je crois que
les agents de l'état courageux alors que
la pression était forte
extérieurement qu'on fait ce travail de
conformité des masques on allait ensuite
distribuer à la population ou aux agents
publics ou aux agents de santé l'ont
fait de manière tout à fait remarquable
des millions et des millions et des
millions de masques y arriver tous les
jours dans des conditions où les
douaniers eux mêmes étaient en
difficulté bien sûr dans leur vie
professionnelle avec des clusters qui se
développait et heureusement que nous
n'avons pas cédé aux pressions
politiques d'élus et parfois des lui qui
prenait les médias à partir disons que
des douaniers l'état bloqué je pars pas
des réquisitions vous avez bien compris
je préfère des vérifications
parce que souvent de temps en temps on
va dire ces masques étaient des faux
vous ne protégez en rien les populations
et les douaniers et l'état a été au
rendez vous sous les quolibets parfois
sur les mises en cause très importante
d'agents publics et les ministres mais
ça il est payé pour ça parce que les
douaniers faisait simplement leur
travail en quelques heures de
vérification de la marchandise qui
étaient livrés et je voudrais leur dire
parce que je vois que c'est une question
qui est rarement posée au représentant
de l'état mais beaucoup d'élus beaucoup
de le chesne entreprises beaucoup aubry
ont pris fait et cause par définition
contre contre l'état qui ralentissait à
sa forme de procédure alors même qu'il
ne faisait que garantir que les masques
d'autres produits devaient être vérifiés
et correspondaient à des normes
protégez ensuite les populations et je
pense que c'était une bonne chose que de
dire devant votre commission merci mais
je suis dans un département où on a eu à
travers l'aéroport de vatry accueillis
au nombre de masques je crois que ça
s'est passé dans de bonnes conditions
en tout cas donc n'hésitez pas à
continuer à l'utiliser pour encore
mesures sanitaires d'autres je ferme la
parenthèse
merci en tout cas s'il ya plus de
questions une question roger de la
libyan virtuo mais pour dire au ministre
en tout cas au sénat ait eu
effectivement des protestations contre
les réquisitions qui se sont produites
jamais contre les contrôles par les
douaniers à peut-être eu ailleurs des
interpellations
mais le contrôle des douaniers parler
c'est normal c'était les réquisitions
que l'on posé problème notamment par
rapport aux commandes des collectivités
merci madame assassi pardon je n'avais
pas vu la main levée pas grave
monsieur le président je vous remets je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre je
crois qu'on est tous et toutes fonctions
de du fait que l'épidémie est inédite et
mondiale et donc se préoccuper de la
façon dont elle a été gérée et et dont
total a été gérée hier et dont elle est
aujourd'hui me semble utile notamment
bien évidemment où la crise perdure et
ou s'aggrave et tout ça me semble
fondamental et c'est parce que c'est
fondamental que la polyphonie
enfin il nous semble dangereux
d'avoir comment dire assister à une
certaine vous dites polyphonie
effectivement il n'y aurait pas
cacophonie mais polyphonie polyphonique
qui a provoqué des interrogations dans
l'opinion publique voire même qui a créé
de langoat voire même aussi des
comportements comme cela été signalés de
rassemblement particulièrement de jeunes
gens qui ne porte pas des masses
et tout ça n'est pas une petite affaire
quand même quand on comprend même si nul
n'est parfait on essaye de faire appel à
son sens des responsabilités monsieur
mini jeux vous n'avez pas répondu à une
question qui vous a été posée tout à
l'heure par madame la rapporteure de
roche à propos de l'application stop
qu'ovide quoi que j'en pense je dis bien
quoi que j'en pense
force est constater que ça ne marche pas
alors les raisons en sont peut-être
multiples mais pouvez vous nous dites
vous dire si elle est toujours
d'actualité d'autant que des bruits sur
et circulent selon lesquelles cette
application pourrait offrir un accès
privilégié aux tests à ceux ou celles et
celle qui possèderait donc cette
application et qui bien évidemment
l'utiliserai je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre je m'excuse auprès de la
présidente qui pose la question si je ne
me suis pas bien fait comprendre mais
justement répondu me semble-t-il à
porter en expliquant que je n'étais pas
en changeant rien chargé de cette
application ni dans mes fonctions
précédentes des dans mes fonctions
actuelles
et donc c'est pas que je suis à bilzen
je suis honnête je sais que ça peut ça
peut vous surprendre peut-être mais
c'est le cas et en l'occurrence je ne
peux que vous dire que les responsables
administratifs politiques de cette
application qui à mon avis est
nécessaire et qui apporte me semble-t-il
des choses notamment dans la seule lutte
contre les accusations du virus relève
dans son application quand dans sa
conception dans ses conséquences dans
son futur de d'autres autorités
ministérielles que la mienne merci mais
je crois madame la présidente que vous
aurez l'occasion de reposer la question
lors de nos auditions et peut-être que
cet après midi des annonces se feront à
ce sujet là car monsieur le président je
sais bien que ce n'est pas le ministre
de l'intérieur qui est en charge de
cette question là mais il n'en demeure
pas moins qu'il est ministre de
l'intérieur et que si j'ai bien en coûts
très écouté le ministre qui a porté le
projet sur la création de ce top cow
vide
selon lui je pourrait rapporter ces
propos
cette application pourrait faciliter le
travail aussi de nos forces de police et
de gendarmerie c'est aussi pour ça que
je vous posais cette question je le fait
que je sois mise un tailleur jeu là vous
échapper nous sur le fait que
l'application stop qu'ovide puisse aider
les forces de l'ordre dans les contrôles
c'est non il n'y a pas de lien
particulier
nous n'avons pas accès aux données
personnelles des poly mais je permettais
vous posez la question vous souhaitez
madame la sénatrice permettez moi de
répondre comme je l'entends et
troisièmement je vous répète une
nouvelle fois mais je sens vous avez
envie que de tenir deux mois d'une
promotion politique afin que je gère
l'ensemble des questions de politiques
publiques mais je pense je pense je
pense que que qu' il faut savoir rester
à sa place je n'ai pas de près ou de
loin eu à connaître à part en tant que
citoyen bien évidemment là des
évolutions de l'application stockée vide
dont par ailleurs je pense évidemment
que c'est une bonne chose pour la lutte
contre le virus
merci en tout cas encore une question
il remarque je me ferais le plaisir de
remettre au ministre la décision du
tribunal administratif de lille parce
que les motifs pour lesquels le l'arrêté
madame bouchard a été suspendu n'est pas
celui qui a été évoqué c'est bien un
motif de fond concernant le traitement
des migrants je le ferais plaisir de
passer une soirée et une nuit une
journée avec mam sénatrice a calé à la
rencontre à la rencontre des habitants
oui alors on compte des rythmes très
bien merci nous en restons là bonne fin
de journée
merci à toutes et tous